hi my name is Jessica Chuy I am a
scientific product manager for the DA
farmer group and today I'm going to talk
about cytokeratin 18 or CK 18 as a
non-invasive biomarker in NASH clinical
trials non-alcoholic fatty liver disease
or natalie is an umbrella term that
refers to a spectrum of conditions where
there's accumulation of excess fat in
the liver of people who drink little or
no alcohol it is progressive disease
that starts with relatively benign fatty
liver or steatosis about 20% of
individuals with naturally developed
non-alcoholic steatohepatitis or nash
which is the more aggressive form of the
disease nash is characterized by liver
inflammation pedophilia damage and
fibrosis some people may progress even
further to develop cirrhosis and
hepatocellular carcinoma or liver cancer
at that point a liver transplant is
generally needed for survival while the
risk of liver related morbidity and
mortality is significantly increased in
Natalie complications from
cardiovascular disease are actually the
leading cause of death in this
population during the past 20 years the
incidence of Natalie has more than
doubled and it is now the most common
liver disease in developed countries in
the United States about 80 million
people or a quarter of the population
have fatty liver disease and are on the
nataly's spectrum over the next ten
years these numbers are expected to
further increase to over 120 million and
even more alarmingly 10 percent of the
pediatric population in the u.s. is
thought to have Napo be the increased
incidence in Natalie is strongly
connected to the epidemic increase in
type 2 diabetes and obesity and this
year nash is projected to overtake
hepatitis C as the leading cause of the
liver transplants
in the US unfortunately physical
symptoms are often silent or nonspecific
to nage which makes it difficult to
diagnose as a result individuals with
nash can remain unaware of their
condition until late stages of the
disease
I should point out here that not
everyone would Napoli will progress to
develop cirrhosis or liver cancer and in
addition Nathalie is generally a very
slowly progressing disease and it takes
years or even decades to progress from
steatosis to cirrhosis and I'll come
back to that point in just a couple of
slides natalie is a complex and
multifactorial disease nash progression
results from numerous events originating
within the liver as well as from signals
survived from the adipose tissue and the
gastrointestinal tract there's now a
consensus for a multi-hit theory that
suggests that nash is the consequence of
several insults acting in parallel in
addition to the padded lipid
accumulation to cause disease
progression
these include genetic factors insulin
resistance adipose tissue inflammation
ER stress hepatocyte injury and a
proptosis activation of hepatic stellate
cells and microbiota dysbiosis so even
though we now have a pretty good
understanding of the pathogenesis of
nash yes there are currently no
fda-approved pharmacologic therapies
insulin sensitizing drugs such as
pioglitazone and metformin as well as
vitamin E have been evaluated as
treatments for nash but each has
drawbacks and limitations weight loss
through diet and exercise remains the
recommended treatment strategy for
napoli but unfortunately only a small
fraction of individuals is able to
achieve a sustained therapeutic goals so
there's really very clearly an urgent
need for pharmacological treatment
options for this foreign population
and the feel of companies that are in
the process of developing Nash trucks is
wide the complex ideology of the disease
offers many therapeutic targets which is
reflected in the multitude of agents
that are currently under investigation
the main categories of drugs that engine
that are in development include those
that affect the various metabolic
pathways so GM de Nova lipogenesis and
bile acid circulation hepatic insulin
resistance eat ketosis oxidative stress
and inflammation and mechanisms
impacting fibrosis the number of trials
clinically and gnash that are initiated
each year has been increasing
exponentially and they're currently
around 8 of 80 active nash trials
underway the first drug with the
National imputed indication of better
colic acid or oak Oliva is expected to
get conditional approval by the FDA
sometime this year but there are many
more drugs with promising clinical
trials data and development so as you
just learned Natalie is a very slow
progressing disease and fortunately this
makes it virtually impossible to use
hard clinical outcomes such as
progression to cirrhosis liver cancer or
mortality as endpoints for drug approval
that is because a large number of
subjects would need to be followed for a
decade or more and that's just not
feasible even just from a financial
standpoint so that has led to the use of
surrogate endpoints that are predictive
of clinical benefit for accelerated
approval in the US and conditional
approval in Europe both the Food and
Drug Administration or FDA and its
European counterpart EMA are now
accepting changes in the race ecology as
surrogate endpoints to test efficacy of
therapeutic treatment in nash clinical
trials the histological response can be
evaluated by a semi-quantitative scoring
system that has been validated by the
nash clinical research network or nash
CRM and can be divided into two
categories the Natalie at cookie score
in the nash verbosity stage
these are determined by history
pathologist examination of the liver
biopsy sample the Natalija activity
score our Nass is a composite of three
values is assigned to this extent
upstair ptosis lobular information and a
parasite ballooning that observed in a
liver biopsy sample each component is
given an individual four and the NASS is
the sum of the three scores values range
from zero to eight and the higher the
score the more severe the disease the
nashville bursa stages range from f0
meaning no evidence of fibrosis to s4
indicative of cirrhosis and one analogy
that I've heard to relate the nasan
fibrosis stage is that of a vulture the
fibrosis stage tells you where you are
in your journey and the NASS tells you
how fast you are traveling along your
route the surrogate endpoints that are
now accepted by the US and European
regulatory authorities for registration
are either the resolution of nash
without loosening up my broseph's and
improvement in play grosses without
worsening of nash or bone the resolution
of nash is defined as the absence of
ballooning so a ballooning score of zero
and little or no lobular inflammation so
score of zero or one improvement in
fibrosis is defined as an improvement in
the National OC stage of one or greater
to be sure after the accelerated a
conditional approval pharmaceutical
companies are still required to do post
market monitoring of clinical outcome in
order to get full approval for that drug
it is important to note that the
histological surrogate endpoints that I
just talked about still require a liver
biopsy sample to be taken but biopsies
have several drawbacks they're invasive
costly there is a rare but not
insignificant risk of complications and
they're inherently prone to sampling
errors in addition they are not ideal
especially for early phase trials since
significant changes in histology may
take some time to it
to manifest or at least longer than
reservation of these early face trials
furthermore because yet biopsies can be
painful study subjects are often
reluctant to have multiple biopsies done
in a relatively short amount of time as
would be required and only these trials
because of these limitations there's
mounting interest in identifying
non-invasive biomarkers that reflect
treatment effect at early time points
and that are also predictive of changes
and histology later on so essentially
what is needed are non-invasive
surrogate markers for these histological
surrogate endpoints imaging tools such
as ultrasound MRI and MRI have been used
to assessing steatosis and fibrosis and
specific biomarkers as well as panels of
biomarkers lipid omics and metabolomics
have been used to monitor changes and
other nash parameters such as
inflammation oxidative stress and eco
ptosis the advantage of these
non-invasive tests is that they can be
done with relatively over a short period
of time however I should mention that as
of now none of these have been validated
by definitive trials to predict clinical
outcomes okay so now I'm going to switch
gears for a minute and talk about
parasite cell death and it's rollin -
then I'm going to going to introduce you
to setup here in 18 and then I'm going
to allow so those two together into a
couple of biomarker assays and talk
about their utility and national
clinical trials so Pat aside cell death
in the liver occurs primarily through
one of two modes either necrosis or
apoptosis
the closest is an accidental form of
cell death that occurs spontaneously in
response to external factors such as
infection or trauma it resolved a loss
cell membrane integrity and the cells
kind of dumps out its contents in
ketosis on the other hand it's a highly
organized and regulated process a
pitocin is another term for programmed
cell death or cell suicide it involves
complex receptor mediated or
Brunell issue initiated signaling
pathways some characteristic features of
a pitocin include membrane blebbing DNA
fragmentation and cell shrinkage a
pitocin also triggers activation of
caspases which are produce enzymes and I
will get back to those on the next slide
in 2003 Feldstein at all observed that
high side AP ptosis is significantly
increased in the individuals with nash
and that the extent of a pitocin
correlates with disease and severity
pata site o'clock ptosis is now widely
recognized as one of the hallmarks of
nash one of the major contributing
factors to have had a friend a pitocin
is the excessive accumulation of lipids
in the liver
this causes in the plasma reticulum or
er stress and mitochondrial dysfunction
and eventually resolve any parasite in
ptosis it patata kepada sites in turn
activate immune cells and hepatic
stellate cells which leads to chronic
inflammation liver injury and fibrosis
parasite each epitarsis is thought to be
an important if not critical driver in
the progression of novelty and
development of fibrosis okay so now on
to cytokeratins
cytokeratins also known as cantons are
intermediate filaments they are part of
the southside of skeleton and they
support the cell structure they are also
thought to have a set of protective
function and they allow cells to adapt
to stresses via various defense
mechanisms in fact inherited mutations
inside hairpins have been linked to over
60 different diseases which supports the
essential site of protective function
one of the members of the site of care
family said it here an 18 or CK 18 it's
expressed primarily in cells of
epithelial origin in the liver CK 18 is
highly abundant in habit site flights
and colon geosite which are the
epithelial cells that line the files up
as I mentioned previously there Joseph
inflammation in a pata salió ballooning
Archie histological features of Nash
balloon Zapata sites are typically two
to three times the size of adjacent
cells and ballooning is associate is
caused by injury to the cytoskeleton and
it has been shown to be accompanied by
loss of cket and stinging in cytoplasmic
CK 18 is also also a major component of
Mallory denk bodies which inclusions
that are made up of damaged intermediate
filaments and that are found in the
cytoplasm of parasites
Mallory tank bodies have been observed
in various liver diseases as I mentioned
on the last slide a Patronus is
accompanied by activation of caspases
these caspases are proteolytic enzymes
that recognize the specific amino acid
sequence on CKD 18 and it is cleaved to
do small fragments primarily by
caspase-9 but also by caspases 3 and 7
when a parasite dies either by a ptosis
or necrosis its plasma membrane
disintegrates and its cellular
components including CKD 18 and seek' 18
fragments are released into the
bloodstream so seek 18 levels in the
blood correlate with the parasite cell
death and both intact CKD 18 and seek 18
fragments have been used as serum
biomarkers for parasite necrosis and
apoptosis CK 18 and its fragments can be
measured in serum and plasma samples
with standard immunoassays these assays
come in two varieties the m65 assays
include the m65 eliza in the m65 teki
death Eliza these assays are based on
two antibodies named m5 and m6 and hence
the name
m65 these antibodies recognize all forms
of CP 18 so both in taxi pa team that is
released from the chronic cells as well
as CK team fragments that are generated
during apoptosis the n65 acids therefore
a measure tool
how to set cell deaths of both a ptosis
and necrosis in contrast the m30 Eliza's
are specific for a pejorative only the
m30 assays include the m30 apoptosis in
the m30 site of death hits the unique
emp'd of the antibody in these kids
specifically recognizes a new epitope on
CK 18 that is formed after the protein
is cleaved by cat faces so it only
detects the caspase t ck in fairness
therefore all measures ketosis so then
just to review and 65 kids measure both
AP ptosis and necrosis and the m30 kids
measure specifically it poisons the two
kids can also be used in combination to
discriminate between the truth cell
death modes if the m65 levels in a
sample is much higher than the m30
levels which shown on the left
it indicates and indicates that the
primary cell death more things necrosis
however if the ratio of the two is
closer to one shown on the right it is
an indication that it doses is the
predominant
cell death mode since it patrols this is
such a common feature of nash CK 18 has
been extensively studied as a biomarker
for Nash and specifically for monitoring
the progression of Natalee several
research studies have have looked at a
correlation between CMC ka-ching levels
and Natalie or Nash total serum total
serum seek 18 and the qasimi's created
CK 18 fragment have been shown to be
increased in both children and adults
with nash compared to healthy
individuals or those with simple
statuses since a Patronus is thought to
be one of the drivers in the progression
of of naturally elevations of CMC
catching levels may therefore therefore
represent active nash serum CK 18 has
also been shown to correlate with each
of the components at the nasa associate
joseph lobular inflammation and
ballooning and in at least two studies
change
c18 has shown stronger positive
correlations with changes in the NASS
than some of the conventional liver
enzymes like alanine aminotransferase
and aspartate or alt and ast and even
though CKD 18 levels are not a measure
of liver cut roses
per se seeking 18 levels have also been
shown to correlate the type OSA stage so
monitoring changes in CA 18 levels and
national indica trials may be useful for
monitoring treatment response and
processing efficacy especially early
phase trials before there's
manifestation of histological changes
and in 2015 of joint workshop at the FDA
in the American Association Association
for the study of liver diseases
recommended a reduction in cell death
markers such as seek 18 as secondary
endpoints for national clinical trials
and SECAM teen has been widened used as
a biomarker in clinical trials the data
on this slide are a bit outdated they're
from 2018
but at that point CK team have been
evaluated as a biomarker and over 115
clinical trials and in sixty trials with
the Natalie or National Invitation most
of these were early phase trials so
phase one or phase two but that's
because at that point there were only a
few Nash drugs and pastes redevelopment
since then more Nash drugs have entered
into Phase three and we know that seek
18 is included as a biomarker and the
majority of Haseley nash trials so we
would expect that side of the pie to be
slightly larger at this point shown on
this slide and it's just a small
selection of blue phase Nash trials that
have used CK aging as a biomarker this
is certainly not meant to be an
exhaustive list that I just wanted to
illustrate the variety of mechanisms of
action of the different drugs the
different trial phases and the
differences in duration of the studies
where CK team has been applied some of
the trials use both of the CK team
biomarkers of both m30 and and 65 and
some only used one to says either if you
chose this or to capture solo total cell
death
each of these studies drug treatment
costs the decrease of his biomarkers
overbake baseline values statistically
significant changes were observed as
early as six weeks after treatment which
is much sooner than significant changes
in histology would be expected in a
couple of studies like the one for M
ricca-san and D or our 928 decreases in
CK teen was seen than just hours of
dosing and this is likely due to a
direct and hitori effect of these drugs
on cafes activity so if using CK 18
might be might be useful as an early
indicator of target engagement and drug
advocacy in early phase Nash trials
keeping in mind that the observed time
cost is probably dependent on the
mechanism of action of particular drug
that is being investigated changes in CK
team have also been shown to correlate
in changes in liver histology these are
two older studies their Phase two trials
and each one of them lasted 96 weeks
these two trials now are generally
shorter the Pippins trial on the Left
evaluated the efficacy of pioglitazone
of vitamin E in adults of Nash whereas
tonic on the right evaluated metformin
of vitamin E in children with McElveen
overall improvements in liver histology
over baseline was a primary endpoint for
parents and a secondary I'm in
pentatonic the graphs in this slide
don't actually show overall treatment
effect but rather subjects were
stratified into those showing
improvements in the histology which is
then represented by the open circle and
those showing no improvement shown in
the filled circles and their CK 18
values were correlated and as you can
see here for both studies individuals
that had histological improvement also
had greater decreases in CK 18 I should
probably mention that changes in alt
which is another commonly used biomarker
also discriminated changes in the rest
ology in these studies here are some
more recent data from a piece trial that
was conducted by Elia to Abell
the safety and efficacy of salon TTIP a
selective inhibitor of ask one either
alone or in combination with some cheese
nap in patients with nash unfortunately
as you may already be aware of last year
that these three trials for salon to tip
i'm namely star left me and Stella
forward discontinued due to a lack of
drug drug efficacy
however salon certain is also included
in Delia's he had Atlas trial which has
looked at dual combinations of salon so
to the psycho sexter circle stat and I
think Juliet is still in the process of
evaluating how to proceed with that
program regardless in this phase two
trial salon two chip treatment alone had
shown promising beneficial effects on
both fibrosis and lobular inflammation
in the sub analysis shown here subject
to stratified into treatment responders
and non-responders similar to the last
slide responders so those that shows
improvement in Pedrosa's or inflammation
are represented by the Queen bars and
non-responders subjects with no change
of worsening of her processor
information as shown in red for each
group the changes in CK team levels were
correlated and the data showed that
treatment responders for both fibrosis
and inflammation also had greater
reductions in both total CK team and
also saccades in fragments as compared
to the non responders like in the pivots
and tonic trials these data support that
changes in CK a team could be reflective
of changes in Lilith's ecology
I want to emphasize at this point that
we're not suggesting that you can 18
alone could serve as a surrogate for
histopathology and nash trials but
rather using seek 18 as a secondary
endpoint could provide valuable early
insight into target engagement and drug
efficacy including for nash drugs with
an anti a photonic mechanism of action
and it could therefore lend support in
the decision-making process whether to
proceed with further further clinical
studies as i mentioned in the beginning
of my talk
nash is a complex disease with diverse
etiology that will likely require a
multi targeted treatment approach and
therefore also combination of by omar
to get the complete picture of the
therapeutic efficacy of the chosen
treatment strategy one more thing
products with a purely direct antibiotic
mechanism of action there are probably
better biomarkers nck 18 since that
grossest is not is really downstream of
the processes that affect and drive how
does that you can ptosis
finally seek 18 also has utility as a
pre-screening tool for managing the
screen male late in national mental
trials one of the biggest challenges for
Nash trials is the cost effective and
timely enrollment of study subject this
is partly due to the large number of not
Charles that are actively recruiting
subjects as you may remember there
currently over eighty trials underway
adding to this is the difficulty of
finding individuals with confirmed nash
this properly there's an overall low
awareness of the disease as I mentioned
in the beginning of the presentation
patients often asymptomatic and even
those with a high likelihood of having
Napoli are really referred to a
specialist and the specialist are
generally the investigators that
participate in the Nashville so there's
definitely a gap in addition subjects
that have been recruited to participate
in the treatment trial have to meet
certain requirements to qualify for a
study subjects are frequently required
to have an ass up or greater in a
fibrosis stage of F 1 to XP
but more than 50% of screen subjects
will not meet these eligibility criteria
so what happens is that these
individuals will get about another
biopsy as part of the clinical trial but
then it turns out that they don't
actually have nash than the box example
is examined or at least they don't meet
the inclusion criteria for the study and
moment this high screen fill they
greatly adds to the cost and duration of
nash trials one strategy to reduce the
screen fill rate is to pre-screen
recruited subjects with serum biomarkers
imaging tests prior to performing a
biopsy with the goal to enrich the study
population that needs the required
features for enrollment as you learned
earlier stickiness associated with pata
salió ballooning inflammation and stage
shows
which are all components of the NASA so
pre-screening subjective seek 18 assays
and selecting those with high zoom
levels could increase the likelihood of
these individuals meeting the required
NASA threshold for inclusion and this
would then of course result in time and
cost savings so to review what I talked
about today Nash is a global epidemic
it is a slowly progressing chronic liver
disease that can lead to cirrhosis
hepatocellular carcinoma and other
medical complications there are
currently no approved drugs for the
treatment of nash but many clinical
trials underway to find an effective
pharmacotherapy one of the biggest
challenges for nash drug development is
the selection of surrogate endpoints
that predict clinical outcome monitoring
changes and still seek 18 levels may be
useful for assessing treatment response
especially in early phase smash studies
improvements in CKD team correlate with
improvements in liver histology and
using seek 18 acid at the pre-screening
tool prior to biopsy may decrease the
screen fill rate in national trials so
thank you so much for your time and your
interest please don't hesitate to reach
out to me directly if you have any
questions comments